well finding a Burmese python in your
backyard sounds like a bad dream
really it may be closer to reality than
you think it's one of the many invasive
species that are devastating America's
ecosystems cbsn Originals correspondent
Adam Yamaguchi recently went to the
Florida Everglades to show us how people
are fighting the threat Wow
oh my god you got to understand I love
these animals I love all animals you
know when I look at this it's like how
many of our native animals with this
thing he get that sighs yeah and how
many more will it eat if you left it out
there so the Everglades that you have
come to know and love have changed
forever because of this animal yeah
absolutely
in their native habitat predators keep
their population under control in
Florida's Everglades there's hardly
anything to stop them except hunters
like Donna I'll keep a hold of his head
so he doesn't bite you
the strength is is incredible
another year and you'll be able to breed
and first year or so you'll probably
have 15 to 25 eggs and you know when
they get to be 18 feet it can have over
a hundred eggs in them so they're just
breeding like you know breathing like
crazy
I'm recoiling just watching that Adam
you have a Gucci or a braver man than I
am
the state actually pays people like
Donna to hunt these these snakes how
successful is that well they put a small
dent in the overall population they've
caught over a thousand or so which
sounds great except there are an
estimated tens of thousands of these
snakes in the Everglades and the scary
part is since they've basically devoured
most of the native mammal species in the
Everglades they're now starting to
venture out in search of food and are
there other ways to combat them bad news
one of the most innovative efforts
really is the market in this dock we not
only look at the Python but we explore
the Asian carp as well as the lion fish
which are decimating their
adopted ecosystems and the market really
maybe maybe the solution people are
trying to essentially commercialize
these fish as the next great protein
alright it's fascinating Adam thank you
very much
you can watch the CBS and original
Burmese python invasion online right now
at CBS news.com slash Python n CBS n
will air a one-hour special with a live
Q&A session on Sunday night at 8:00
Eastern 7:00 central